turning overseas Pakistan is bracing for
a new round of violent protests
following the arrest of former prime
minister Imran Khan his supporters clash
with police across the country yesterday
at least two people were killed and
dozens were injured authorities say
hundreds of Khan supporters have been
arrested MPS tired reports on the
turmoil
convulsing with political unrest
after dozens of security forces smashed
their way into a local court and took
former prime minister Imran Khan into
custody seen here in a wheelchair
surrounded by Shields and wearing a
bulletproof helmet
Khan is Accused in several corruption
cases ranging from improper property
deals to allegations he unlawfully sold
State gifts charges he denies and says
are politically motivated
his supporters have reacted with Fury
protesting in several cities Pakistan's
all-powerful military looms large over
the nation's politics having ruled the
country for more than half of its
existence and have given their backing
to the current prime minister Shaban
Sharif
but since Khan was ousted from Power
last year what he says was an
orchestrated plot the nuclear-armed and
strategic Washington Ally has been
spiraling into Political chaos chaos
which has seen the U.S embassy in
Islamabad Council all Consular services
and the fear now is the country of 230
million people has been plunged into an
abyss that may not be easy to come out
of for CBS mornings London